microchips implanted in human bodies
could transform the way we tackle many
everyday tasks some workers in Sweden
are already developing and volunteering
volunteering rather to have chips
injected into their hands that
technology can make some tasks easier
and reduce the amount of personal items
employees need to carry John Blackstone
looks at the controversial trend and how
it could put your privacy at risk in a
Stockholm business complex employees
gain access not with key cards but with
a wave of a hand this is something that
you can use just like a key badge
at a recent tech conference hottest
robot explained how a microchip
implanted in his hand makes his life
easier it replaces all the keys and
cards that used to clutter his pockets
I used this many times today for example
to unlock my smartphone to open the door
to my office
Sherlock calls himself a bio hacker we
bio hackers we think that the human body
is a good start but there is certainly
room for improvement the first step in
that improvement is getting a microchip
about the size of a grain of rice lived
under the skin suddenly the touch of a
hand is enough to tell the office
printer key this is an authorized user
it felt pretty scary but at the same
time it felt very modern the microchips
are radio frequency identification tags
the same technology widely used in
things like key cards the chips have
been implanted in animals for years to
help identify lost pets now the
technology is moving to humans a tech
startup called dangerous things has sold
tens of thousands of implant kits for
humans some to tech companies in Europe
show blood even organises implant
parties where people can bond over
getting chipped together I love gadgets
and now I kind of feel like I'm a gadget
myself even a car door can be tweaked to
open with a touch but each touch leaves
a digital footprint and that can
compromise privacy it also seems to be
one thing if retailers can track me on
my phone to see if they can get me to
buy some socks or underwear
it's a different thing if my employer
can see where I am see what I'm doing
when I'm off the job this is serious
stuff we're talking about a non-stop
potential connection to my body I can't
turn it off I can't put it away it's in
me that's a that's a big problem even a
dedicated bio hacker has concerns it's
very easy to hack a chip implants so my
advice is don't put your life secrets on
a chip implant somebody put an implant
inside we had found me this morning back
in 2004 The Manchurian Candidate
suggested a future where humans are
chipped and controlled we have been
warned it's about educating the people
and giving every person the tools not
only how to use the technology but more
importantly when it's being used against
you but bio hackers also predict the
next generation of chips will save lives
by monitoring health and fitness for now
being chipped means never having to say
you're sorry you forgot your key card
for CBS this morning John Blackstone San
Francisco I'm fascinated by this I've
always thought it was the future that it
would carry your medical records that it
could track your fitness that it could
bet you could buy your groceries with it
right like an Apple pay or something I'm
in yeah I'm skeptical I'm scared of
becoming a cyborg but if you guys go
first I'll join you